Hey everyone, so my name is Lauren, and my
YouTube channel is Cosmo4confidence and
you can seen my information below, to find
my own videos. But today I am doing for Psych2Go.net
To find out more about the discussion I'm
going to have today, go to the "Selfie Chronicles,
It's Not That Bad", you can find the link below.
The author is Risha Maes. So, I'm sure many
people have heard about why selfies are bad.
I know a lot of people say: "Why are younger
people taking selfies because it's terrible
for you," but then you have people who are
younger than you, who say: "I love selfies
because I love taking a picture of myself
posting it online and seeing people compliment
me, basically." So what are the actual problems
with taking selfies? According to Dr Pamela
Retlidge, she did a study for the psychology
in taking selfies, and she stated that taking
selfies is detrimental to a person's mental
health in narcissism, low self esteem and
attention seeking behaviour. When I found
this article, at first, I completely understood
that, because the main reason why people take
selfies is to get that attention, to get people
to like their photo, to give them a compliment
and taking too many selfies as in a mental disorder,
but it does have characteristics of body dismorphic
disorder. Body dismorphic disorder basically
is the mental illness that involves, that
one's own appearance is defective and that
it has a flaw and that other people can see that flaw.
And I know many people spend sometimes
hours trying to get that perfect selfie, a
lot of people has this whole thing about them
that they want, a certain angle and what's
the perfect smile, what's the look you want,
and you end up taking a million selfies and
you always try to find the perfect one. So,
what's the whole thing with this, is you are
trying to find the perfect selfie and most
of the time, say you had a pimple on your
face, you will do anything to hide that pimple
and you can do that with selfies, you can
angle it differently, you can edit the selfie
if you wanted, and it completely makes you
look at your own flaws and make sure that
you don't show them. There are good things
about taking selfies. I know sometimes I like
to take a selfie. I think I look nice and
sometimes I like seeing that people compliment
me, so you know, it's human. I think it's human.
What do you think? I want to hear what
you think, so make sure you write below what
you think are the pros and cons about taking
selfies, and check out the article itself
so that you can read more about it. Make sure
you visit: Psych2Go.net, their Tumblr,
their Twitter, their Facebook and Instagram. So make
sure you go and find them. Go to my channel,
Cosmo4confidence and subscribe to me, so
I want to hear your opinions. So comment below.
Like this video and subscribe to the channel,
have a fabulous day.